okay welcome back everybody before we
jump live in the william hughes trial
just want to give you an update on what
we were just live in before the break we
were live in a pre-trial hearing for
james and jennifer crumbly the parents
who were charged with involuntary
manslaughter for their role in the
oxford high school shooting they are the
parents of the alleged shooter
i want to go to you dr pearson real
quick
there was an interesting aspect there in
terms of what the judge was saying uh
because it was mostly the judge speaking
in this very very short pre-trial
hearing what did you take away from the
judge's comments
well the judge was directing counsel to
uh
to
work together to
come up with an agreement there was
going to be an independent a lawyer that
was going to be appointed for both
parties to be able to understand
the ramifications of potentially waiving
a conflict
and
my biggest concern is i've never seen a
judge get that that much into the waiver
of a conflict um conflicts come up all
the time uh in court cases um and in
this situation it appears the same
lawyers representing both defendants and
that can become sticky uh because it's
possible that you know at some point
somebody points the finger at the other
and the next thing you know uh both you
know the lawyer has to withdraw from
both cases in the middle of a jury trial
i mean it's it's simply a a nightmare
and so for a judge to insert themselves
that much into it i i i'm a little
concerned about that given given the
risk and the uh argument for ineffective
assistance of counsel later on well uh
not surprised considering how pro high
profile this trial is and a lot of
people are finding it's also a unique
legal case to charge the parents of a of
a school shooting uh so there's going to
be a lot riding on this like you know i
don't think the judge wants any kind of
hiccups here i will let you know that
the crumbly hearing has been continued
until april 5th at 9 00 a.m there was
supposed to be another hearing tomorrow
that has been cancelled by the judge
we'll obviously follow any more updates
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate lawn crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box